- [Interviewer] Alright, Stephen.
- Yes.
- Stephen, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- San Diego, California.
- [Interviewer] San Diego.
And tell me about your childhood.
Did you have both your
parents when you were a kid?
- [Stephen] I did, for a moment.
My dad's a Vietnam Vet.
My mother got pregnant with me in 1970.
I also had an older sister that was-
She got pregnant with-
My mom's from Puerto Rico.
My dad was in the Navy,
so he brought her over
she's 15.
They made a home in San Diego,
and I came in '70 and
my other siblings came.
I'm the only boy.
So, six of us all together.
And my mom said my dad came back from
his two tours of duty Vietnam,
he was a different person.
You know, he does suffer
from bipolar, PTSD.
He's on top of it now.
He's sober now.
But at that time when I was young,
one, two, three years old
I can remember one or
two, but three, four,
I can remember vividly.
He would pick any reason
to beat my mom down.
I mean, like how man beats a man.
Not, not just slap around and push.
He'd whoop her.
And it, and it, it traumatized me
'cause I used to love
this man is my father,
but same time, I'm the
only other boy in the house
who was supposed to protect,
and this man is beating my mom.
I used to hate him at same time.
So, I was always torn from,
from, from a young age.
Then he always expect me to step up
and be the man of the house
and do this, be a man.
He's from Louisiana.
He was very old fashioned.
So you know,
I don't know if that has
anything to do with it.
But he very old fashioned.
I mean, when I'm gone, you're
in charge of the house.
You're the boy.
These are girls.
You take care of them.
Anything comes up, weird or strange,
I'm gone fuck you up.
That's exactly what he did.
So I used to take beatings
for all kinds of reasons.
So, you know, very young too,
because I thought this is how it was.
See what I'm saying?
So I got accustomed to the whoopings.
And then it got, I don't
know, like stranger than that
because my dad was all
fucked up in the head, man.
He drank all day.
He worked,
he kept a roof over our head,
but Vietnam twisted him, man.
You know what I'm saying?
It twisted him.
Even my mom said, he's
not the same person.
Like, whatever happened over there,
fucked him up, you know,
to the point where he would love us
but at the same time abuse us.
And what I couldn't stand,
because between him and my mom,
my mom Puerto Rican, she's
very old fashioned too,
so she was like,
whatever goes between me and your father,
even if he's damn near killing me,
that's between me and him.
You know what I'm saying?
So I was like, whatever.
But when he started going
off with my sisters,
that's when it stopped.
I think it was like 79.
I was nine years old.
My dad was,
I was watching Battlestar Galactica,
I love that show. Right?
And my dad took my sister in the room,
and I was hearing my sister scream.
And he used to drink Heineken,
and for some reason, I grabbed the bottle,
and went in the room,
smacked him with the bottle.
That's the first time
I ever inflicted violence on my father,
at nine years old.
And my mom whooped my ass,
everybody whooped my ass,
but I didn't care
because you know,
whatever you do to my
mom, I don't accept it.
Whatever you do to me?
I guess it is what it is.
But my sisters though, never.
- [Interviewer] What was
he doing with your sister?
- He was real drunk.
I remember he, when he was
drunk, he's stupid, man.
He was molesting my sister.
I asked my sister a couple of times,
she won't talk about it.
And she made me promise I'd
never bring it up again,
but I wanted to know what
she was, he was doing to her.
That's when I was nine years old.
At first, thoughts of
murder came to my mind.
I just want to kill this man,
but I love him, my father,
but I want to kill him.
Then he started messing with me.
He doing good now.
He's my dad.
He's back in St. Louis right now
taking care of my grandmother.
He's, he's sober now,
born again Christian,
part of the Freemasons, and all that shit,
whatever the hell, I don't care.
But I still remember that, that man.
- [Interviewer] What, was he
drinking a lot or using drugs?
- Oh man, back,
when he came back from Vietnam,
my mom'll tell you he was all fucked up.
I remember he used to
bongs over the house.
This is the seventies.
So we have bongs over
the house, and you know,
he playing Black Sabbath,
nodding off, and you know,
playing Jimmy Hendrix, nodding off,
and I'd just be like,
why is daddy always going to sleep?
I didn't know he was back
in there shooting dope.
And my moms was always
trying to hide it from us.
But he, he, he was,
I use my, he was my
father, but I hated him.
But I loved him the same time.
But, I think the only
thing he ever taught me,
really, was to not trust nothing, no one
and violence is a universal language
that everybody understands, even animals.
You can talk till you're
blue in the face to people,
once you go upside their head,
turn into a different thing.
Then they get some understanding,
or they don't and just
get beat the fuck up.
And that's what my dad
used to do to my mom,
my dad used to do to my sisters,
and I knew he was doing more than that.
Because he even got on me one time,
like you're a little bitch.
You're not, you're not a man.
You're a little bitch.
You can't, he'd fuck around,
and he caught himself spanking me.
And just weird shit, man.
I was a little kid.
I didn't understand it.
He my father,
I mean, you don't put, you don't
put your fingers in my ass.
You know what I'm saying?
Then I started thing,
what the fuck he doing to my sisters.
That's why I want to kill that man.
I want him dead.
I wanted to murder him.
I wanted to stab him,
while I'm stabbing him,
stick my fingers in him too
(inaudible)
You know what I'm saying?
But at the same time it tore me
because he wasn't always a bad man.
He is a little league coach,
and we'd play little league,
and he's into sports.
And I played Pop Warner.
I played JV, varsity.
He's proud of that.
But as far as being a man,
he never looked at me as a man.
I don't think to this day
he looks at me as a man.
You know what I'm saying?
He's different now.
He's born again, he's,
all that good stuff.
He's sober, all that.
He's a good man now.
But he slowly going crazy too.
I can tell
'cause the ghosts are haunting him,
and they haunt me, too.
And I believe,
and he gets mad at me somehow.
You know you, you're,
you know, you a gang,
you a gang member now.
You, you, you doing this, you doing that.
You doing stuff you ain't
supposed to be doing.
You played JV, varsity.
You could've went to the pros.
You could've been pro.
You always, you know, criticizing me.
But then saying something, I tell him,
you made who the fuck I am, man.
You made me this hateful, violent person.
You made, you did this.
I used to watch him beat
the shit out of my mom
just cause you'd come home from work,
and the, the, the, the plate
wouldn't be warm enough
or hot enough, you know what I'm saying?
Those, that type of shit.
And don't get it wrong,
my mom ain't no punk.
And this fucked me up too.
I remember one night,
it was like about like 70, 79, 80,
back when, I love this
show, Man from Atlantis,
Man from Atlantis, I just
love that show, right?
It was coming on,
and my dad used to home about six o'clock,
so anytime from eight
o'clock in the morning
until six o'clock at night was happy time.
Me, mom, my sisters, go
to school, come back,
have a treat, snack,
chill, everything's cool.
But six o'clock roll around,
the dark cloud sinks in
'cause, you know, dad's coming home.
You know what I mean?
So it's about time for him to come home.
She's cooking.
But I noticed, he used to drink Heineken.
My mom took a bottle for the
12 pack, put it in the freezer,
hours before she started dinner.
I'm like, why she do that for?
I was watching.
Okay. Whatever.
I guess her an my,
she already knew how my dad
was going to be coming in.
Sure enough, he came in tripping.
Where's dinner?
What the fucks going on?
Whoa.
What the fuck you sitting there
looking at that faggoty ass shit on TV?
What the fuck is this shit?
Fishman, talking shit.
I'm just sitting ignoring him.
But I noticed my mom kept be
looking at me with these eyes
like, don't even trip.
So my dad, she gave him dinner.
Everything went well.
He didn't smack her up this night.
Thank God.
My sister's all in their room.
I'm sitting watching my show
because it's be Man from
Atlantis and then the Hulk,
Lou Ferrigno on my show.
So he's talking shit.
Give me a beer.
So she gives him a beer.
Pops it, he drink it.
He finishes it.
He's talking shit.
He starts talking shit to my mom.
I already notice him to go.
I figured he getting to smack her up.
My mom said, Larry, you want another beer?
He said, yeah, give me another beer.
She looked at me.
I looked at her
because I knew someone
was going to go down.
She went to the freezer
where she put that Heineken
hours before.
It's stone frozen all the way through.
She grabs it by the neck like this
instead of grabbing it like this.
Didn't open it.
Walks it to him.
Here's your beer, Larry.
Smacks him right across the face with it.
Busts his whole head wide open.
I was about like, not even
10 years old, like nine.
My dad set me on the lap
because he drove a red sheriff.
He sat me on his lap, says steer,
I'm gonna push the gas.
Just steer when I tell you
'cause he was all fucked up,
and my mom, she was taking
him to the hospital.
And it fucked me up because I'm like,
I never seen my mom get like that.
But then I realized,
no, my dad whoops ass,
this is respect and fear
'cause I fear him.
My mom, she showed me a
different side of her today
through violence.
It made me fear her.
So basically violence
breeds respect and fear.
And I've grown up with my life with that
and it's fucking me all up.
And it's all behind the abuse
my father gave me, my mom,
my sister, when he was in that zone.
But now he's different,
and I know it's sad.
I don't applaud him for it,
but I can never forget.
I can never unsee what he did to us.
- [Interviewer] And as an adult,
how has that affected your life?
Where'd you go after you left home?
- [Stephen] Streets with the homies,
you know, gang banging
living with the homeboys,
and get into drugs and shit.
And shit I ain't, my people
never wanted me to be part of.
And violence.
Violence, and that's what I'm known for.
Everybody knows it.
My nickname, my nickname is SB.
Shady blood.
They'd be like, SB going to get with him.
He, he's violent.
That dude, he don't, he
might not know a lot.
He's very educated.
He knows how to play football.
He tells you about some things.
But one thing he does know is violence.
And I don't like that, man.
I don't like violence.
I don't like that
because it's an ugly thing, man.
But sometimes, man,
my way of making sense of of it was this.
You're gonna understand me,
and you're gonna respect me
if I have to beat you down
damn near to death to do it.
Just what my dad did to us.
But it made me hate him,
so I expect people to hate me too.
- [Interviewer] You did prison time?
- Yeah.
Yeah. Quite a bit.
- [Interviewer] What for?
- Why?
For robbery, shootings,
grave bodily injury,
assault with firearms,
assault with weapons,
criminal threats, terrorist threat,
possession of weapons,
stupid shit.
I just, and I don't blame my
father for making me who I am
because I had a choice,
but I knew no better when I was a child.
I didn't know.
And then that day he, he fucking raped me,
because that's what I call it.
I don't give a fuck 'cause
it's full sexual weird shit.
He stuck his fingers in my ass, man.
Called me a bitch.
He's my father.
I love him.
There's still sometimes
I hate that fucking man.
Even though he's different now.
Okay. You're different now.
But then he acts like
that shit never happened.
Me and him have fought three occasions.
I mean fist fights
as a grown man, like
I'm not a boy no more,
I was grown.
Just recently, about
not even five years ago,
and we ain't talk since.
But he asked my uncles,
my aunties, and my,
how, how's he doing?
How, how, how's Stephen doing?
How's Stephen doing?
I don't know if it's my fault or his.
I don't know whose fault it is.
Sometimes blame God.
I get angry at God like, fuck,
what type of shit is this?
I didn't ask for this, man.
I didn't ask for his life, man.
I asked for none of this shit.
You coulda just get me
unborn and irrelevant,
but you gave me this life.
You know, I was supposed to
find reason and profoundness
with it or find my calling
and all this bullshit.
When it's just bullshit.
To me, it's like a
living fucking hell, man,
to live with this shit.
I'm very protective of
women, very protective
because I see, I see him
on days beating my mom.
He used to beat like a hate her, man.
I've hit, I've hit
women a couple of times.
Twice in my life I've hit a female.
And I hate myself for it.
I just, man.
I don't know, man.
He fucked me up, man.
That's my father.
I love him,
but at the same time, I
fucking hate that nigga, man
He took me in the room that day,
told me I'm a little girl.
I should be like my sister
and be a little girl.
And then, I would have
accepted the whooping,
I would have accepted the beating,
but he, he defiled me, man.
- [Interviewer] And are drugs
are part of your life now?
- No, I just drink now.
I've let drugs go.
They're no good for me.
I just drink.
I drink a lot.
A lot.
And that was his hang up, too.
I don't the drug thing.
Sherm, PCP, crys, crys it nasty.
Went to the cocaine.
But alcohol, alcohol, makes me numb.
It makes me not care.
But at the same time, it makes me angry.
And I'm angry drunk sometimes, man.
You know, if I'm around
somebody I don't like,
or if I feel some type of way.
Oh boy.
I mean I'm banned from
clubs all around Pasadena.
Shit, I can't even go near them.
You can't come in here.
The last time I was there,
two people went to the hospital,
shut the club up,
just crazy shit, man.
And I wonder where the
fuck this shit comes from.
And my grandmother says is rage.
She goes, you have rage against
the things that have to as a child.
This is her son she talking about,
my father.
But that's why I love my granny, man.
She's like, she keeps it real.
She goes, he was a torn fucked up man
when he came home from Vietnam.
He was a young kid when
he went to Vietnam,
when he enlisted into the Navy,
he was 18 years old,
went to Vietnam when he was like 19, 20.
And he was a door gunner, you know.
Door gunner that just go clear villages.
I remember one time I asked my father,
this probably like 1990, 1991,
I just got out of Y.
He goes, you a bad, big bad gang banger,
like drive by shooter.
How many you done killed?
I was like, man, don't
ask me no shit like that.
How many fuckers you done killed?
And I seen his whole face is just fall.
And I know he did two tours in Vietnam.
He's a door gunner, and I know that.
He said, I don't even know.
I don't even fucking know
how many people I killed.
I think that's a big part
of what fucked him up.
Because you know, in
the military, you know,
originally from San Diego, my
whole family's from San Diego,
back, back South too, but San Diego.
My grandfather's a CV in the Navy, my, my,
he did two tours in Korea.
He did World World II.
My dad, two tours in Vietnam.
I was supposed to go to the Navy.
That didn't work out.
'Cause I went to jail
real, young kid, but.
You know, and that's where
you follow orders, man.
That's it.
It fucked my dad up, man.
'Cause he's, you know,
when I look at picture
of him when he was a kid,
like, he was a happy child, man.
I could see me in him.
Now he's all fucked up.
Don't get me wrong, he's living his life,
but it's like a marionette,
like I know them, them ghosts
and them ghouls are still in there.
- [Interviewer] And do you have kids?
- Yeah.
I have quite a few kids.
I have seven kids.
- [Interviewer] Did you raise them?
- Half-assed, I been in and out of jail,
but always been sure they
had everything wanted.
But my daughter, Erica,
that's my third oldest,
she said the one thing I
ever wanted from you, daddy,
is the one thing you never gave me.
What the fuck you mean?
I gave you everything.
Money, clothes.
You'd go, you were the fliest shit.
Whatever you need, I give you.
What do you mean?
She goes, the one thing you never gave me
was you, mother fucker.
She goes, you always in jail.
You know.
They're doing well.
My kids are all good.
I got one son in prison.
You know what I'm saying?
But that's just how to the cookie crumble.
Know what I'm saying?
He got fucked up out there on that meth,
and he from Harlem 30 down this way.
And the 30s, he a Crip.
Got off that meth one night,
got tripping and barricaded himself
inside of a Burger King
on Jefferson and Crenshaw,
tripping.
Got 18 years for it.
There, you know.
That's my responsibility.
You know what I'm saying?
My father, man, I love that man.
But he me fucked up
because he was fucked up.
I think when in Vietnam,
it fucked him up bad.
And he, he just, he
volunteered for another tour.
Why would you do that?
But I guess he was young at the time,
felt like, hey, fuck it.
I'm military, it's my duty.
He came out all fucked up.
Now, he's just all fucked up.
He has to take all
kinds of medication now.
He's bipolar.
They originally diagnosed
him as manic depressive,
now it's bipolar.
- [Interviewer] What
emotions do you deal with?
- Anger,
rage,
compassion.
I care, but I care to hard.
I love hard.
But when somebody, I feel really betrayed,
my love turns into hate real quick.
But I still love that person,
but it's hatred at the same time.
It's weird.
I don't know how to explain it.
Especially with the females
in my life, man, you know.
I mean, I've got girls
that love me to death.
Know what I'm saying?
But I love them too, but,
you know, women play
games in the, (inaudible).
You know what I mean?
The vindictiveness and the,
the, what's is that called?
The manipulation.
and I'm not the smartest
person in the world,
but I am very, very intelligent.
And I'm very, I know
what the fuck's going on.
I see, I call things where I see 'em,
and I, the way I see them is reality.
I don't deal with facades and, and,
and fronts and playing along.
Nah, I call like I see it.
So anybody that knows me will tell you,
I'm the most honest person in the world.
I'll tell you exactly
the fuck how I see it.
If I see a girl playing you
and playing with you and
trying to just milk you,
and you come to me,
you're a friend, tell me,
Hey, what do you think about this?
Hey, the bitch is milking you, man.
The bitch is playing you for a fool, man.
But I love her.
I like,
no, but you ain't seeing it.
I'm seeing it.
And guess what?
Later in the game, you
you'd come back to me,
you were right.
'Cause I know the game, man.
I know life.
People always have a ulterior motives,
some more than others.
And some ulterior motives
that other people have
aren't negative.
They might want the best for it for you.
But most people,
I hate to say it like this,
this is the most plainest
way I can say it,
are maggots.
They're maggots.
They're, they, they, they feed on death,
carrion and disease.
And they revel in it.
Like we said a minute ago,
they'll never admit that though.
Oh, it's too much drama.
I can't stand it.
No, but you revel in it.
And you have no other way.
And just be scandalous
and scurvy and slimy.
It's just your way.
Most people are like that.
But then you got the ones
on the side that are,
they're gold, you know.
I like to think I'm gold,
but gold don't stink, and I stink
because I'm tainted.
You know what I'm saying?
Not going to blame it on my father
'cause last thing I did in my life,
I abused my damn self.
The only time I'm any good for anybody's
when I'm in a relationship.
'Cause I live for her.
I want everything to be good for her.
So whatever I got, I gotta
maintain and do for her,
make sure she's sheltered
and protected and good,
I'll do it her.
But by myself, I wouldn't give a fuck.
I'm at a point now in my life,
I don't care whether I live or die.
I think dying would be better.
'Cause my life's just been
fucking bullshit, man.
It's the feelings, that-
The shit I seen, the shit I went through,
the shit my father did to my mother,
the shit he did to me.
And God knows he did
it to my sister's, man.
'Cause he won't talk about it.
Now I see him getting older,
and he's 68 years old,
and he's, he's demented.
He's going crazy.
I'm telling you he's, he's losing it.
- [Interviewer] What's, what's
the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- The most important lesson
I've learned in my life
is that love don't love nobody, man.
But there is love.
There is
the righteous, honorable thing to do
as a man, a woman, as a person, period.
Integrity, dignity,
it's a beautiful thing.
But it's a, it's going to stink.
There's no more honor.
There's no more-
That's the way I see it.
I'm not saying I'm right.
People are, we're regenerating.
We're not progressing.
As a human race, we're
regenerating back to,
to the abominations we
originally the were anyway.
- [Interviewer] Degenerating?
- Degenerate, regress, whatever.
I mean I know the Bible.
I'm, I grew up in the church.
You know what I'm saying?
I know, I know the Lord.
I don't believe in God.
I know he's real.
That's me.
There is, there is a higher power.
I believe that.
But,
like I said a minute ago,
we're regressing, degenerating,
back into the abominations
we originally were anyway.
So basically, I hate to say it like this,
I think there's no hope for us, period.
I don't think God loves us.
I think he just allows
us to exist, to suffer,
and in the end, put the
flame out, be done with it.
Because it's just too much, man.
I hope that I'm wrong.
I pray I'm wrong.
But my father,
the shit he went through,
the way I'm seeing him now,
it's like a love and hate
because I hate to see him degenerate
into this, you know, the depression
and playing the part, you know?
But I know he's fucked up.
Last time I talked to him,
he just bust out crying for no reason.
And then my grandmother going to say,
Oh, it's the medication.
Man, that's bullshit.
It's the ghosts.
It's the haunting.
It's the, he knows, man.
'Cause sometimes we go there.
Starts talking about my
mom, I said, you know what?
You want to talk about my moms?
Let's talk about all the times
you whooped her ass, man.
Let's talk about that.
Lets talk about the times
you used to come home drunk
and your, and your, and
your mother fucking meatloaf
wasn't hot enough, you
used to beat her down
like when Spinks beat,
mother fucking, you know,
Larry Holmes or some,
like, you know what I mean?
Let's talk about that.
He don't wanna talk about that.
Then he gets mad,
and wants, you know, roar up on me.
I told you, we had three
fights, fist fights,
and every time he's whooped me.
My dad could fight.
He's from the south.
And he, you know, military.
He can fight.
I'm good too,
but every three times, he whooped my ass.
He says not going to be
another time we gone fight.
We won't do this ever again.
Because next time we do it,
it's going to be the end for both of us.
And I said, just all right.
But now, he's like a shell of a man.
He's a shell now.
And when I was younger,
I wished that for him.
But now-
- [Interviewer] Alright,
Stephen, thank you so much
for sharing your story, man.
- For sure, man.
- [Interviewer] You've been through a lot.
- Yeah, but life is what it is, man.
And I'll always hold on to this.
My mom, she always telling me this.
What don't kill you
only makes you stronger.
And maybe I appear stronger,
but my heart is shattered.
That's it.
- [Interviewer] Thank you, man.
- Thank you.